[موسيقى]
حياكم الله قتل نحو تسعه اشخاص وجرح
العشرات ليله وفجر الثلاثاء في اشتباكات
قرب ميداني النهضه ورابع العدويه حيث
يعتصم مؤيد الرئيس المعزول محمد مرسي
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما مغزى تزايد الهجمات على مسيرات
ومواقع اعتصام مؤيدي الرئيس المعزول في
مصر
مؤخرا وما هي المسارات التي يمكن ان يقود
اليها هذا العنف في التعامل مع المتظاهرين
المؤيدين
لمرسي مازال العشرا من القتلى والجرحى
يسقطون في مصر منذ عزل الرئيس محمد مرسي
تثير الاحداث الامنيه اسئله عن مدى تحمل
اجهزه الامن المسؤوليه عن تامين المظاهرات
السلميه والاعتصامات التي تقول جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين ان جهاز الشرطه هو من
يتحمل مسؤوليه ما يرافقها من احداث
دمويه الثال عش من يوليو انه عيد في مصر
في ذكرى انتصار تاريخي للجيش وفي العيد
تكون الفرحه لا مشهد الدماء ولكن المصريين
باتوا واصبحوا على مشهد دموي فلم يكتب
لهذه المظاهرات ان تبقى من دون هذه
المشاهد قتلى وجرحه سقط اغلبهم بالرصاص ظل
المصدر مجهولا وظلت الاتهامات متبادله بين
اكثر من فريق لكن الثابته ان قوى الامن
المصريه وان ظلت تنى بنفسها عن تحمل
مسؤوليه هذا المشهد الا انها تبقى مسؤوله
من وجهه نظر المتظاهرين عن حمايتهم ما
داموا سلميين من يطلق الرصاص ومن يريد
للمشهد ان يتحول من مشهد سلمي الى مشهد
تتواتر فيه الهجمات والعنف اهو الجيش ام
البلطجيه ام الشرطه التي لم تكن يوما على
وفاق تام مع القوات المسلحه ويتهمها
كثيرون بانها تحمل في نفسها ما تحمل منذ
ثوره الخش من يناير تجاه جيش انحاز للشعب
وحمل الشرطه مسؤوليات العنف والقبضه
الامنيه ايام مبارك مشاهد تنذر بدائره عنف
يخ ان تدخل البلاد فيها وخشيه اخرى ايضا
من عوده العقليه الامنيه للتعامل مع كل
صغيره وكبيره من دون ان تترك مكانا للعقل
والحوار موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين من
القاهره الكاتب الصحفي عصام العبيدي نائب
رئيس تحرير صحيفه الوفت وهنا في الاستديو
معنا الكاتب الصحفي وائل قنديل مدير تحرير
صحيفه الشروق استاذ وائل ابدا معك يعني
ربما نحاول ان نفهم المشهد قبل ان نسال من
المسؤول عن هذا العنف المتزايد الارقام
مخيفه يعني في تزايد وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه تتحدث عن 150 قتيل في الفتره
الماضيه وطبعا مئات الجرحى اليوم فقط كان
هناك نحو 100 جريح كيف يفهم هذا الوضع
يفهم ان ال هناك اصرار من النظام الحالي
على وتسرع وتعجل في مساله فض الاعتصامات
الموجوده في ميادين القاهره والمحافظات
باي ثمن كما لو ان هناك
استحقاق ربما يكون دولي او اقليمي يحتم
عليهم الانتهاء من هذه الاعتصامات وازاله
مظاهر هذا الاعتصام في اقرب وقت ممكن مما
يشير الى ان هناك حاله ارتباك داخل معسكر
السلطه الحاكمه في مصر على الى الى الحد
الذي دفعها لان تسكت عن كل هذا الدم ان لم
تكن
مشاركه في صناعه هذا المشهد الدموي
بامتياز ويؤخذ هنا في الاعتبار ان صحف
القاهره اليوم صدرت وتحمل جميعها تصريحات
لمصادر امنيه مسؤوله تتحدث عن انه تم رصد
مجموعات مسلحه تتجه لمهاجمه المعتصمين في
ربعه العدويه وفي ميدان نهضه مصر اذا من
يملك المعلومات من يملك التقارير والماده
الكافيه بان هناك مجموعات
مقصوده هذه المجموعات يعني ي نفهم من
كلامك ان يعني حاله ربما فوضه حاله
من كما تقال بالانجليزي ال سبريشن لابد ان
نحل هذا الامر ان ننتهي منه باسرع وقت
ممكن هذه العصبيه في الاداء تكشف عن ان
هناك ارتباكا في معسكر السلطه وان هناك
ا زمن محدد مطلوب في فض هذه الاع هذه وجهه
نظر لنستمع من الاستاذ عصام هل تتفق مع
وجهه النظر
هذه اهلا بك يا فندم واهلا بزميل ن
وائل يعني لا اتفق مع ذلك على الاطلاق لان
القوات المسلحه لو ارادت فض اعتصام ربعه
العدويه حسب ما قال خبراء عسكريون فهي
قادره على ذلك في خلال ساعات معوده خاصه
ان هناك بعض الاوقات لا يكون عدد
المتواجدين
فيها يقاس الا بالمئات خاصه وقت الظهيره
انما يعني في اعتقادي
ان الامن لا يستطيع تامين مظاهرات اصبحت
يعني
مظاهرات
اجراميه وليست مظاهرات سلميه على الاطلاق
وراينا ان اغلب هذه المظاهرات يكون فيها
الاخوان المسلمون حاملون للمولتو والخرطوش
واخرهم الهجوم
فجر اليوم على ميدان التحرير ومحاوله
اقتحامه تستطيع تامين المظاهرات المسلحه
نعم ولكن من يسقط في النهايه هم نتحدث عن
متظاهرين هم الذين يسقطون يعني هذا هو
الاساس هنا وهذا ما يلفت نظر كثير من
المنظمات الحقوقيه ويدفعهم الى
التساؤل لماذا لا يتم
حمايه المتظاهرين وتوفير سبل تمنع وقوع مث
هذه
الاحداث لاني كما قلت لك الامن يستطيع
يعني يعني يستطيع حمايه المظاهرات السلميه
بالفعل انما المظاهرات العسكريه المظاهرات
المسلحه مظاهرات العصابات التي تخرج وفي
يدها المولوتوف والخطوه وغيرها اذا كان
رجل الامن في حد ذاته يصبح يعني رهينه و
وفرصه ذهبيه عندما يقومون بخط خطفه وراينا
اليوم عندما قاموا بخطف ضابط في مصر
الجديده وامين شرطه وعذبوهم وهم الان وانا
احدثك موجودون في مستشفى الشرطه يعالجون
من الاصبات التي لحقت بهم من العصابه
طابعه العدويه التي اختطفتهم في وضح
النهار اذا كيف يقوم الامن بتامين عصابه
تخرج وهي تغير على غيرها من المعتصمين
الاخرين في ميدان التحرير وغيرهم من
الاماكن المساله يعني في منتهى الصعوبه
اذا كان الامن في حد ذاته يصبح هدفا لهذه
العصابه فكيف يؤمنها هو نفسه يعني لسمع
لنسمع رد على هذا الكلام من السيد وائل
قنديل الزميل بيتحدث انا عندما ذكرت ان
قلت معسكر السلطه الموجوده هو تحدث فورا
عن القوات المسلحه وكان القوات المسلحه هي
التي يعني تحكم مصر هذا
اقرار ما نراه الان منذ الامس وهناك انا
توقعت منذ منذ صباح امس ان هناك مجزره
ستحدث في هذا المساء بالنظر الى تصريح
المصادر الامنيه وبالنظر الى محاوله تهيئه
مناخ اعلامي يقول مثلا استطلاعات راي ظهرت
فجاه تقول ان 71% من الشعب المصري معترضين
على مظاهرات رابعه العدويه واعتصامات
رابعه العدويه اذا كانت هناك بيئه مهيئه
تماما لتوجيه ضربه خطيفه انا لا استطيع ان
استبعد من المشهد البعد الاقليمي والبعد
الدولي نحن نعلم ان هناك مواعيد ضربت
استئناف
المفاوضات المراجعه الدستوريه لا استئناف
المفاوضات الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه بواسطه
مصريه في غضون ايام محدده يعني هذا يعني
ترى ان هذا هو الاستحقاق الاهم الابرز ليس
الابرز ولكن لا استطيع وانا انظر الى
الصوره وانا استكمل عناصر الصوره ان اغفل
هذا هذا البعد لا استطيع ان اغفل ايضا ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال
يجد مشكله في الاقرار بشرعيه ما جرى في 30
يونيو او في 3 يوليو وهناك ضغط عام في راي
عام اوروبي ضاغط على حكوماته لمراجعه ما
جرى ان العالم لم يحسم حتى هذه اللحظه اذا
ما كان الذي جرى في 30 يونيو او 3 يوليو
هو استكمال لثوره او انقلاب الاتجاه يميل
الى انه انقلاب وهذا يفسر عصبيه التصريحات
من مؤسسه الحكم في مصر الان عندما يخرج
المتحدث الاعلامي في رئاسه الجمهوريه
ويستخدم مصطلحات من نوعيه ان من يخاطب
الاعلام الغربي هو خائن وعمي يعني هذه
اللغه ربما تليق بكاتب صحفي يعبر عن وجهه
نظر او معارض يشتط في خطاب انما ان تكون
هذه لغه الخطاب الاعلامي الصادر عن مؤسسه
الرئاسه فهذا يكشف عن حاله عصبيه وحاله
ارتباك في حقيقه الامر ثانيا ان الاعتصام
حق الاعتصام والتظاهر مكفول في كل
المواثيق العالميه وفي كل القوانين
والدستور المصري ايضا فلماذا يكون
الاعتصام في في زمن محمد مرسي واقتحام
القصور الرئاسيه و
وهذا التجاوز وال في والاعتداء على مؤسسات
دوله وملتوف يكون عملا بطوليا وثوريه في
لحظه والان نطلق على المعتصمين
والمتظاهرين الذين يرفضون
ا انقلابا عسكريا او اختطافا للسلطه
بواسطه الاراده العسكريه نعتبر ذلك عص ج
القاب حتى تذهب ابعد من ذلك تحمل
الاخوان المسلمين مسؤوليه ما يحدث في ساحه
الاعتصام مسؤوليه القتلى الذين يسقطون
استاذ عصام يعني في النهايه ما المطلوب من
هذا الطرف الذي يعترض على ما جرى في 30
يونيو يعني هل بيدهم غير الاعتصام التظاهر
ما المطلوب منهم في هذه المرحله لكي يعني
يعبروا بطريقه مقبوله لديكم عن في البدايه
اه اه اود في البدايه ان انا اتكلم بس على
اعلق على تصريح الزميل وائل عندما قال بان
انني تحدثت عن القوات المسلحه وانا اقصد
ذلك لان القوات المسلحه
هي الدع الواقي للامه هي العمود الخيمه هي
الوحيده القادره على مواجهه هذه العصابه
وراينا ان الشرطه بمفردها لا تستطيع
مجابهه ذلك خاصه في سناء وفيفي الكثير من
الموا العصابه من تقصد العصابه تحديدا
يعني هل هؤلاء من من يخرجون في الشارع في
مين العصابه يا فندم
عندما
اه المؤيدون لمحمد مرسي لو تظاهروا وجلسوا
في اماكنهم عشرات السنين لما اقترب منهم
احد ويكفي ان نقول ان امام البيت الابيض
لازال حتى الان هناك شخص ينصب خيمه
اعتراضا على حرب الخليح الج البيت
مو افهم ما تقول حتى نكون دقيقين يعني انت
استعملت وصف عصابه من من تقص دعيني دعيني
انا اقول ا انا اقول من يحمل سلاحا فهو
مجرم من يحمل سلاحا فهو عصابه من يدعو الى
القتال فهو عصابه زعماء الاخوان المسلمون
على منصه طابعه كلهم يستخدمون افواههم
كمنصات لاطلاق الصويخ للصواريخ ومحاوله
تحريض انصارهم على الاستشهاد ويكفي ان
نقول لان صفه حجازي بالامس قال قدمنا اربع
شهيدات ونحن اليوم نقدم الاف الشهيدات في
الانتظار بل ان الاخوان المسلمون يعني
يقدمون النساء الان في المظاهرات
ويجعلونهم في المقدمه ويتسون بهم دروعا
بشريه هم والاطفال وهذا يعني افتقاد لابسط
انواع الرجوله والشهامه ولا يقبلها العربي
ولا المصري على نفسه ولا على كرامته
فعندما نقول ان من يحمل السلاح فهو بلطجي
وهو في اطار منظومه متكامله فنحن نقصد
مؤيدي محمد مرسي الان تخلوا عن السلميه
تماما وراينا الان اشتباكات في كل مكان
يعني في التحرير في شبه الخيمه في السويس
لانهم
يريدون
الميادين نعم عندما تحول هل هل تعد هذه
يعني حركه
استفزازيه من ثم تستوجب انا اندهش كثيرا
من ان نعتبر المسيرات المسيرات المتظاهرين
ال عملا مؤثم وعملا اجراميا بينما كانت
عملا بطوليا عندما ذهبت الى قصر الرئاسه
واقتحمت قصر الرئاسه في حين ان هؤلاء
عندما خرجوا في مسيرات الى الحرس الجمهوري
سقط منهم العشرات بالرصاص الحي واظن ان
تقرير منظمه الهيومان رايتس واتش يشير
بوضوح الى ان قوات النظام قوات الجيش
المصري وقوات الشرطه المصريه استخدمت
الرصاص الحي
واستخدمت القوه المفرطه في التعامل مع
المتظاهرين والمعتصمين استغرب ايضا عندما
يعني عندما تغنينا طويلا بدور المراه
المصريه في ثوره 25 يناير وهذا الصمود
وهذا التحضر وهذه المشاركه ونعتبر الان ان
مشاركه امراه مصريه لكونها فقط محجبه عملا
خسيسا وعملا ضد الرجوله وما الى ذلك يعني
هذا للاسف الشديد نحن دخلنا في مرحله
شديده الخطوره من
العنصريه تجاوزت العنصريه السياسيه الى
العنصريه المجتمعيه اصبح لدينا الان نوع
من الشيفونيه المجتمعيه بعد الاقصاء الس
سياسي نريد هناك خطاب يتحدث عن ضروره
اباده هؤلاء وتطهير المجتمع منهم هذا
الخطاب صدر من اصوات عديده جدا داخل معسكر
30 يونيو وهو خطاب ربما استعماله الطرفان
بطرق مختلفه في مراحل مختلفه ان رائحه
الدم تشحذ ماكينه الغضب وتشحذ صلاح الغضب
وكلما سالت دماء بيزداد الحشد في الشوارع
مع اخرى وهذا ربما ما سنناقشه بعد الفاصل
ناخذ فاصل قصير نناقش بعده مسارات التي
يمكن ان يقود اليها تعمد استخدام العنف في
التعامل مع المتظاهرين والمعتصمين من
مؤيدي مرسي نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش مغزى تواتر الهجمات ضد مسيرات
ومواقع اعتصام مؤيدي الرئيس المعزول في
مصر
وعصام عبيدي ربما الكل يعني يبح حث عن
المسؤول من هو المسؤول طرف ثالث عوده
لاجهزه امن مبارك ذهب البعض الى الحديث عن
ان الشرطه هي من يقوم بهذا العمل في
محاوله لرد اعتبارها للانتقام مما تعرضت
له اثناء ثوره ال5 من يناير وبعدها ما
ردك يعني دعينا نوضح اولا بان لا احد في
مصر يستطيع ان يمنع المتظاهرات من السير
في المظاهرات وال المسيرات السلميه على
الاطلاق وما قصدت ذلك و انما انا قصدت
الدفع بهم كدروع بشريه هم والاطفال كما
حدث امام الحرس الجمهوري وكما حدث في
شارع شهد من قبل ثلاثه ايام
متصله ولكن يعني النساء والاطفال كانوا
موجودين ايضا اثناء ثوره 25 من يناير
كانوا موجودين في 30 يونيو في يعني هذا
المنطق ربما يعني عندما يت تكون في شيء من
الازدواجيه في المعايير عندما نتحدث فربما
هذا ما قصده الاستاذ وائل في الاشاره الى
ان يعني دائما يستعمل كان دروع بشريه هذا
كلام مردود عليه اريد ان اركز على هذه
النقطه نقطه الشرطه لو
سمحت الاختلاف واضح اولا بين الواقعتين في
25 يناير كان الجميع يحمي النساء ولم يكن
على الاطلاق يتم الدفع بهم في مقدمه
المظاهرات والا كان ذلك يعني ضد الانسانيه
والكرامه والاستاذ وائل كان شاهدا على ذلك
في ميدان التحرير كان الجميع يحمي النساء
ويجعلهم في الصفوف الخلفيه اما قتل
المنصوره وشهدت القضيه ليست قضيه وجود
نساء القضيه هي وجود التهديد اصلا يعني
وهذا ولا ننسى ان نساء ايضا تعرضنا اللي
اللي ما تعرضنا عليه في ميادين التحرير في
ميدان التحرير وهذا الممر لا اريد اذا
سمحت لي ايضا استاذ لا اريد ان اركز عليه
كثيرا لاننا يعني الموضوع الاساسي الذي
نتحدث عنه المسؤول عن العنف الان في
ميادين مصر من الذي يتحمل مسؤوليه الاشاره
الى الشرطه ورد الاعتبار هذه اريد رد منك
على هذا
الموضوع لا في اعتقادي ان المسؤول الاول
عن هذا الموضوع هو الاخوان المسلمين
وقادتهم الاخوان المسلمون الذين يسعون الى
استدراج القوات المسلحه و استدراج الشرطه
لافتعال معارك لتلويث صوره وصفحه الثوره
المصريه المجيده ثوره يونيو المجيده
فيحاولون بقصد بقض الامكان افتعال المعارك
الوحيده تلو الاخرى حدث ذلك امام الحرس
الجمهوري وامام وزاره الدفاع رغم ان هناك
تحذيرات سابقه بعدم الاقتراب من الاماكن
العسكريه بل ان جميع الدول العالم تمنع
الاقتراب او مهاجمه المنشات العسكريه فكيف
نعتبر ذلك يعني من باب المظاهرات السلميه
المظاهرات السلميه ربما من احرج ايضا يعني
الاحراج حصل ايضا للجيش هنا يعني امام
الحرس الجمهوري وهذا ما يدعوني للسؤال
استاذ وائل قنديل يعني الحديث عن انتقام
هل هذا في محله هل هذا يعني في شويه
مبالغه برايك دعينا نقول ان ما يسمى بثوره
30 يونيو وهي ليست ثوره هي انقلاب 30
يونيو هي الثوره الاولى في التاريخ التي
تخرج فيها الاجهزه
الامنيه تهدف ضد النظام ظام يعني باي
معيار تكون هذه الثوره الاجهزه الامنيه
التي قمعت ثوره 25 يناير والتي تحمل من
المرارات والثارات العميقه مع ثوار 25
يناير خرجت في 30 يونيو على راس هذه
المظاهرات وراينا صورا لافراد الشرطه
يرقصون م محمولين فوق اكتاف المتظاهرين في
ميدان التحرير يرقصون معهم
وبالتالي في كل نقطه دم كانت تسيل سواء في
حكم المجلس العسكري او في حكم الرئيس محمد
مرسي كنا نسمع فورا من يخرج ليقول ان
شرعيه النظام سقطت وان كل نقطه دم تسيل هي
مسؤوليه النظام مسؤوليه اجهزه النظام
الحاكم بصرف النظر عن كان هذا الدم دم
معارضين او مؤيدين بالمعيار ذاته الدم
الذي يق امس وهو الرقم ربما وصل او تجاوز
عدد شهداء موقعه الجمل في
2011 المسؤول عنه هو النظام المصري الجيش
المصري والشرطه المصريه والنظام المصري
عموما مسؤول عنه اخلاقيا ومسؤول عنه
سياسيا ومسؤول عنه جنائيا اردتك ان تعلق
على هذه النقطه يعني هذه اللي بدا البعض
يروج لها انها فعلا يعني محاوله لرد
اعتبار للشرطه الان هذه فرصه ل يعني لانه
تعرض لاهانه لاذلال خلال الفتره الماضيه
هو الان ربما طريقه ل لرد الاعتبار توافق
ما يروى عن نشطاء محيدين وعن شهود عيان
تعرضوا الى مواقف مع الشرطه المصريه ما
يروى من هذه الحكايات يؤكد ان الشرطه
المصريه تحتفل هذه الايام باستعاده مجدها
واستعاده صول جانها على الشعب المصري يعني
عدنا الى المعادله التي اوجدت مبررات
واسباب ثوره 25
يناير في النهايه ربما يعني لا يمكن ان ان
نتحدث عن وضع بهذا الحجم من السوء
وتزايد وتيره العنف والدمويه دون ان ان
يعني نحاول ان نستش
المخرج استاذ عصام العبيدي ابدا معك كيف
ترى المخرج كيف ترى
افق الخروج من هذه
الازمه في اعتقادي ان على الاخوان
المسلمين وقادتهم تحديدا ان يدركوا ان
المساله ليست نهايه العالم هناك استحقاقات
قادمه وانتخابات قادمه لمجلس الشعب ومجلس
الشو والانتخابات الرئاسيه يستطيع اذا
كانوا واثقين ان هناك لهم مؤيدون في
الشارع يستطيعوا الوصول الى هذا الشارع
والعوده مره اخرى الى مقاعدهم في البرلمان
وحتى مقعد الرئاسه بل ان حتى الرئيس محمد
مرسي القانون لا يمنعه من ان ياخذ
الانتخابات الرئيسيه القادمه لكن يعني
ينبغي ان يستعدوا الشعب حتى لا يكرههم
الشعب اكثر من ذلك غضب الشعب قاسي وما
يحدث الان من تصدي لمظاهرات في كل ارجاء
مصر هو غضب شعبي بامتياز لان الناس كرهتهم
وزهقت وما يحدث في سيناء من قتل لجنودنا
كل يوم وحتى يعني يعني مجرد استقواء
بالخار وهم الذين كانوا يدونون من قبل منس
بالخارج استذ ع يعني تقول الناس كرمهم
وربما ايضا يعني كان هناك حديث عن ان
اصحاب المتاجر
و الساكنين الاحياء ملوا من محاوله
التعامل مع المتظاهرين مرافق الحياه
تقريبا تكون متوقفه ولكن اليس صحيحا ايضا
ان التصرفات التي حدثت بعد 30 يونيو ايضا
ادت الى نوع من التعاطف بين في اوساط ناس
لم يكن يحلموا ابدا بانهم سيتعاطف مع
الاخوان المسلمين اليس صحيحا يعني حتى نضع
يعني لا نكون فقط ننظر الى الى الامور
هكذا يعني نقول ما لنا وما علينا كل طرف
ارتكب اخطاء الا توافق ان هناك اعداد
كبيره من الناس ايضا بدات تتعاطف مع
المعسكر
الاخر على الاطلاق يا فندم لا يمكن ان
يتعاطف احد مع اناس يعني
يقتلون المتظاهرين والمعتصمين
ويحرقون المتاجر لا يمكن ان يتعاطف مع احد
يقطعون الطرقات بدعوه الصلاه فوق فوق كبي
6 اكتوبر لا يمكن ان يتعاطف مع احد حول
اعتص ل سلخانه لتاديب المارين يعني مجرد
افراد عاديين يمروا في الشارع عند رابع
العدويه يتم سلخه ونزع اظافرهم وقتلهم
بسكاكين هذه ليست انسانيه وليست اسلام لا
تقولي عن تعاطف على الاطلاق الاخوان
المسلمون بالفعل خشر الشارع المصري تماما
لكن هم هناك فئه منهم تحديدا وتيار
الاسلامي السياسي لانهم يعتقدون ان نهايه
الاخوان هو نهايه لتيار الاسلامي السياسي
في مصر على اطلاقه وان هناك بعض المغرر
بهم يعتقدون ان هذه حربا على الاسلام كما
يهمهم قادتهم ويغسلون ادمغتهم بان هذه حرب
على الاسلام وان هؤلاء اعداء الاسلام دون
ان يدركوا ان حربنا مع رئيس فاشل لا علاقه
له بالاسلام
الموضوع لكن هم يريدون نسل ادمغه انصارهم
حتى نوازن الامور يعني هناك اخطاء بلا شك
ارتكبت من جانب الاخوان المسلمين من جانب
الدكتور مرسي ومن ثم يعني حتى نستشف
المستقبل لابد يعني ان ان ان ح المساله في
انها صراع بين الاخوان المسلمين او
الاسلام السياسي وبين السلطه الانقلابيه
الجديده هو اختزال مخل للغايه 26 يوما من
الصمود في الشوارع هذا اكبر بكثير من طاقه
الاخوان المسلمين على الحشد هذه شرائح
تمثل الشعب المصري كله الذي ادرك وايقن
انه جرى اعتداء عليه شخصيا باهدار صوته
الانتخابي اهدار منجزه الديمقراطي الذي
حققه بعد ثوره 25 يناير وبالتالي اذا كنا
نتحدث عن مخرج فاننا نتحدث عن اعاده
الامور الى احترام الدستور واحترام
الشرعات الدستوريه واحترام حق المصر
المواطن المصري واحترام وقت البرنامج
اعذرني لان الوقت انتهى شكرا جزيلا لك
وائل قنين مدير تحرير صحيفه الشروق وشكرا
جزيلا ل الكاتب الصحفي عصام العبيدي نائب
رئيس تحرير صحيفه الوفد وشكرا لكم على
متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج مراخ في
[موسيقى]
ملا